de police c'est le film français qui
entrent en compétition ce soir une très
jolie distribution avec nous ce soir
karine viard et marina foïs bonsoir mes
demoiselles merci d'être avec nous
d'abord dans quel état d'esprit êtes
vous ce soir
êtes vous du genre plutôt tendu avant de
monter ces fameuses marches plutôt très
excité ensuite alors paul et c'est
d'abord un regard intense sur un univers
de la police finalement plutôt méconnu
celui de la brigade de protection des
mineurs
et dans cette brigade vous formez toutes
les deux un un binôme c'est cela on
découvre quoi en fait le quotidien de
ces hommes de ces femmes qui qui
prennent des coups à la fois physique
mais aussi psychologique tous les jours
surtout mais enfin l'abri de la brigade
des mineurs ils sont censés il s'occupe
de tout ce qui est violent ce qui touche
les mineurs intra familiales ou extra
familial et la particularité de leur
travail c'est qu'ils sont dépositaires
des faits mais au fond il n'y a pas d'
enquête ya pas de spectaculaires n'y a
pas de suspense c'est juste ils
entendent les victimes et les prévenus
n'est mise en cause alors c'est vrai que
ces policiers qui appartient à la
brigade des mineurs ils font ça comme
une profession de foi c'est-à-dire être
recevoir comme ça la parole de l'enfant
c'est c'est une façon d'être policier un
peu particulière alors on affine les
suites d'un les y est les jurés leur
travail et dans leur vie privée
on va regarder justement à quoi
ressemble police avec deux aces
les premières critiques parlent d'un
film coup de poing intense comme fut le
l 627 de bertrand tavernier il ya
quelques années touchant mais aussi
drôle pourquoi ces rires au milieu de ce
malaise on va en parler avec nos invités
dans un instant mais d'abord le film
parce qu'elle deschamps et vincent
bouffartigue alors ça tu nous dis qu'ils
exploitent
et puis tant en protégeant frais dans un
foyer et après midi
soit tu dis rien tu continues comme ça
tu fais du bic pocket encore pendant un
an puis dans un an comme c'est plutôt
mignon il faut sur trottoir depuis la
puissance à l'écran comme dans la presse
en quelques mots tout est dit choc coup
de foudre
l'accueil par la croisette est à l'image
du film coup de poing de maïwenn la
benjamine de la compétition reconstitué
avec ses acteurs le quotidien d'une
équipe de la bpm la brigade de
protection des mineurs
mr enlevait son bébé de six mois elle
dangereuse antécédentes sitôt qu au prêt
à porter tous des policiers souvent
jeunes qui vivent leur métier comme un
sacerdoce
la réalisatrice les a côtoyés pendant
des mois et tous les cas d'enfants ce
mal traités qu'elle évoque dans le film
son vrai qu plus l'impression que le
sujet m'avait choisi que moi tellement
c'était c'était gta pkoi comme un truc
qui était indiscutable c'était mon
ventre maïwenn elle-même joue une
photographe qui suit la brigade jouerie
nuit entre interventions des positions
et interrogatoires des moments de doute
de liberté de vérité détient en grèce
qu'il pleure layec a claqué l'examinions
lecce misérabiliste ça y est halal et là
j'en ai à [ __ ] ou simple on comprend
ce qu'il dit je comprends la question du
je n'ai pas envie qu'on a une mauvaise
opinion la bns ne comprend extrêmement
bien c'est juste que là on est en train
de manger en est tout temps du super du
tout cas merci une nouvelle partition
pour le chanteur de ntm
juste une chose je savais déjà de façon
qu'on aime
à la poste où c'est un milieu sans un
monde il ya des corps partout il ya des
gens qui font leur métier un coeur
l'accord mon regard sur la police mais
mettra son goût de faire défiance a
changé mon regard sur l'individu de
manière générale quoi filmer à l'énergie
police est porté par un casting
formidable trait acteurs et actrices au
service d'une oeuvre forte presque au
service d'une cause un casting
formidables karin viard et marina foïs
sont avec nos d'abord un mot de la
réalisation d'un film tourné caméra à
l'épaule qui est à la frontière du
documentaire c'est ce qui renforce
encore l'intensité de ce film à la
frontière du documentaire en réalité
c'est vraiment une fiction et mais il ya
un tel sentiment de vérité qu'on pense
que c'est presque du documentaire mais
en réalité c'est vraiment de la fiction
il ya un lyrisme souffle dans ce film
qui fait que ça dépasse vraiment juste
la réalité je trouve
on a l'impression qu'elle vous a laissé
une forme de liberté dans le jeu est ce
qu'il y a eu un peu d'improvisation ou
pas du tout oui il y en a toujours avec
maïwenn parce que de toute façon sa
liberté qui est vraiment la chose la
plus forte chez elle elle est
contagieuse
c'est pas quelqu'un qui enferme et la
rive passe sur plateau nuit avec des
références mais avec des idées
préconçues
elle est ce qui compte pour elle c'est
ce qui va se passer en vrai sous ses
yeux donc
c'est impossible de prévoir et on peut
pas avec quelqu'un qui vous regardent
comme ça s'enfermer dans un savoir faire
tout ça donc
et puis dès qu'elle entend quelque chose
qu'elle aurait déjà entendu qui
ressemble à quelque chose qu'elle
connaît elle dit stop elle arrête elle
fait refaire donc voilà alors alors je
vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est à la
fois un film bouleversant sur le
quotidien des victimes mais aussi drôle
pourquoi parce que ces policiers ont
besoin forcément de de sortir de soupape
il ya une intensité en tout cas dans
leur façon de faire ce travail qui fait
qu'à un moment donné tu es obligé de
healy a par exemple une façon de parler
avec les enfants est une façon de
s'exprimer des uns par rapport aux
autres
c'est un travail assez intense et la vie
pour eux dans l'espace du travailler
plus et plus vibrante et plus intense
plus intéressante que la vie qui est
plus banales comme ça et puis c'est le
fcc à rire comme celui qu'on a dans les
inter moiré beaucoup quand quand la vie
est atroce
parce que c'est comme ça parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix voilà merci beaucoup à tout
les deux ça s'appelle police films
signés maïwenn et qui est en compétition
ce soir à cannes belle soirée